[Music]
these four walls see so much beauty
and so much hard work
anna nicoliner and dennis rodkin are two
of the balshoe's biggest stars
mikulina has been performing the role of
clara in the nutcracker or marie as
she's known in the russian version
since 2006.
[Music]
every performance gives you the feeling
of a fairy tale of magic
and that's the difference between this
and other shows
[Music]
it's almost a miracle it's on as covid
ripples through the bolshoi on its
virulent journey through russia
[Music]
that means some unexpected extra shifts
for a lot of the dancers
have you had to step into roles that
you're not prepared for oh yes like
today we have uh
la baya there in evening and i was not
supposed to do it
uh but i'm doing it and i've been told
like yesterday you're doing it i was
like okay
because that girl got sick and even like
if one person
got like sick then all of a sudden
everyone in a dressing room
or or the partners they have to also
isolate
and like like lots of people just go out
in one day
hi everyone i hope you're
all well and healthy and safe but at
least it's better than lockdown
to fill her days then turazashvili gave
online classes
and down to your knee i really kept
myself
busy and occupied and tired and
i was doing it every single day like
every single day and
it helped me a lot yes the [ __ ] was
closed for six months
dancers were sent a bar and special
flooring so they could practice at home
performances restarted in september and
despite high covert numbers inside and
out
the doors have stayed open since you are
required for your own safety to give
social distance
and to wear face masks
the show has gone on but only thanks to
substantial state subsidies
when the theaters reopened they were
allowed to sell 50
of their seats but at the end of
november because of the covet situation
that was brought down to just 25
that meant that a lot of people this
christmas saw their tickets for the
bolshoi council
dennis rodkin had the virus already in
september
he's grateful for the antibodies and for
the fact that he has an audience to
dance
for people in russia love ballet so much
that i'm sure that even if there are
only five percent of spectators in the
auditorium
we'll still feel 100 support from them
i'm very grateful to all of those people
that come to our performances and
support us
support from spectators is the most
important thing for any performing
artist
the nutcracker is the story of a little
girl's dream
an escape into a fairy tale where toys
come alive
nutcrackers turn into princes and good
triumphs over evil
it's a magical escape from a bleak year
for those lucky enough to see it
and for the performers too
down in magnay sky news moscow